the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys in this video I'll discuss and show
you some kind of proof that are going
favor of ginjury being firstborn son of
Cersei and Robert Baratheon be aware
that this is a theory for a TV show only
not for the books the last living man in
Westeros with Bharati own blood within
em the guy whose fate had been unknown
after escaping from the island of
Dragonstone
with help of sir Davos Seaworth at least
unknown until a few months ago when
leaked photos confirm that this guy
ginjury will finally appear in season 7
Joe Dempsie aka ginjury has been firstly
spotted on September of 2016
spotted by a fan in your nylons balfus
City Airport but it didn't confirm much
since actors that have been killed order
fate is just unknown on the show have
been known for visiting out actors on
their filming locations for dinner
parties and marketing events but gingers
appearance in season 7 became certain
thing a few months ago when filming took
place in Bari cos we could clearly see
ginjury killing two gold cloaks that his
father's Warhammer whereupon they headed
to Dragonstone few days after those lake
scenes in King's Landing we could see a
few leaked photos English Gingrey stands
beside Daenerys John Jorah Davos and
Tyrion a scene that doesn't surprisingly
as John dowager on injury put the bolt
and that together to the north beyond
the wall on a mission that I explained
in my previous videos however now that
we know for sure that injury will
finally appear in the upcoming season
after a long absence and probably a huge
role in the last eight season which I
explained in a video about ginger estate
let's focus on being loose identity
let's see what kind of evidence show
gave us for this theory in which
ginjuries the firstborn son of Cersei
and Robert since the first season we
know that ginjuries son of King Robert
Baratheon as when stark recognized it at
the moment he laid his eyes on him due
to the fact that Renly Baratheon is also
said to greatly resemble his older
brother in his youth ginjury also bears
a striking resemblance to Renly
additionally Brienne of Tarth is dis
fact in the fourth novel of the fantasy
series a song of ice and fire by george
RR martin in fees for crowds briefly
believing that the ginjuries Renly who
has
turn from the grave which was a result
of her being badly wounded in a
five-cent of her loss in consciousness
while in the show injured son of Robert
just like he is in the books but in the
show there are also some hints of green
room being son of Robert and Cersei
while in the books it's definitely not a
case but his theory ganger is a
black-haired
beautiful son that serves to describe to
Caitlyn in a second episode of the first
season as son she said he died of a
fever it's also important to point out
that the show gave us a few let's go to
get a chance they're going favor to this
theory for an example when aria is
ginjury about his mother the only thing
he remembered was her yellow hair as he
also told the same to her father Ned but
it's time begins you also mentioned that
her mother was probably some tavern
wench
there's also scene in which search they
admitted that she describes herself as a
tavern wench when she had a signal
meaning sujini in order to avoid other
people recognizing her which might but
only might mean that sir she stopped by
to visit her son every now and then
while having a secret meeting with her
brother and lover do you think that it's
a coincidence that injury remembers her
yellow hair mother who he said looked
like some tavern wench and searched his
anchors saw that she was resting as a
one well it certainly might be a
coincidence and I would surely say his
coincidence if it was any other show but
Game of Thrones a show in which every
spoken word has its meaning you might
wonder why would search to give up on
her firstborn son while the answer is
pretty simple sir still alive Roberts is
the very first day since their wedding
night I should reply to herself on that
assertion that she always hated Robert
quoting hated him I worshipped him every
girl in Seven Kingdoms dreamed of him
but he was mine by oath and when I
finally saw him on our wedding day in
the Sept of Baelor lean and fierce and
black-bearded it was happiest moment of
my life and at night she crawled on top
of me stinking of wine and did what he
did what little he could do and
whispered in my ear Lyanna your sister
was a course I was a living girl and he
loves her more than me this Cersei
sentences say so how much Cersei hated
Robert eventually resulted as him being
killed by Circe's intrigues she didn't
love Robert and they don't want to raise
his
as an heir of the throne so by this
theory she gave a vague entry in secrets
and lied about his debt there are a few
possibilities about this theory the most
likely could be the third sieve with
Jamie's help replaced the real baby who
would be in this theory ginjury with
some what's called the ordinary lowborn
baby
whereupon they poisoned him and caused
baby's death they probably used the same
kind of poison as Petyr Baelish and Lysa
arraigned dead to kill John and RAM also
died of a fever
the theory continues there becomes an
explanation on how did Cersei and Jaime
manage to replace the baby in poison
this same baby which would be very
simple to manage since Robert never
attended none sir since childbirth and
Cersei Stated herself Robert would
always go hunting when she was about to
give birth which confirms my statement
from a few moments ago let me tell you
again that this theory in which these
ginjuries matter is certainly not
possible in the books since the little
dark-haired boy that Cersei gave birth
in the show does not exist in books I'm
not sure if producers made a mistake
Maggie who brought aside in the season
five premiere that search doodles have
only three children among other
prophecies of which most of them have
already came true according to the
writer Bryan cogman it's not a mistake
cog man who is an enemy award-winning
television producer and screenwriter
also known for writing nine episodes of
Game of Thrones series was directly
asked about this maggy's prophecy only
sure why that source is black hair span
with Robert wasn't included in her as he
called it official count of children
because he died in cradle
unquoted what he said exactly meg is
just speaking of the three official kids
who have lived and were known the black
haired baby was kept quiet I'm also
wondering if Jon Arryn who is it ginjury
a few times before his dad actually
found out that ginjuries the first and
true born son knows his dear friend and
King Robert Baratheon while Ned Stark
thought that he found out the same truth
as John did but in my opinion Ned was
wrong Ned found out that the injury's
son of Robert true but voted Florida
rain beside that I found out that
ginjury is not only Roberts bastard that
ginjury is not son of some lowborn woman
but the son of Cersei a son Cersei and
Jaime gave out and replaced as I've
already explained earlier in this
video which they could have managed to
do without any obstacle since Robert was
hunting at a time thirsty gave birth to
their boy
and only saw a dead body what a
conversation between Cersei and Jaime on
John's funeral imagers express concern
for their lives in case John told truth
Robert was the truth about his first and
the only true born son
it will also raise a question about
Fleur there is that which we all know
was orchestrated by a little finger
what if Petyr Baelish killed the hand of
the king of course the side effect that
it gave him an opportunity to may
realize that who he has already been
manipulating with but also to prevent
lor the rain to tell the truth Robert to
tell him that he has the oldest son the
trueborn son your thoughts right now are
probably why would Littlefinger even do
that what good would it bring to him
vali floored Aran managed to tell King
Robert about his true and eldest son to
them bring Peter chance to put the Seven
Kingdoms into the state of chaos from
which he personally benefited it
wouldn't bring him a chance to set up a
war between the Lions and both it
wouldn't bring him a chance to
manipulate with Ned Stark which resulted
just as he planned with the war if Lord
Arryn told to King Robert's about
ginjury Robert would have been still
alive the injury would have been his
heir Ned Stark would have been in the
hand of the king and the Seven Kingdoms
wouldn't have been in the state of chaos
which wouldn't bring any success and
benefit to Littlefinger I'm not sure if
the story is going to be revealed as a
true one or is just me and my we're
thinking but this whole theory makes
sense to me let me know your opinion on
this theory in the comment section down
below but I'm not sure if this theory is
going to come true the injury's role in
the upcoming season is a certain thing
my opinion ginjury who is known as a
skilled blacksmith will be very
important the last eight seasons since
I'm expecting from Sam to find out how
to make Valyrian steel a form of metal
that was forged in the days of the
mighty Valyrian freehold I'm expecting
from Sam to find out how to make it
while is that citadel and I'm also
expecting from ginjury to forage source
of role earring and steal the weapon the
living side desperately needs the only
weapon that can decide dragonglass skill
White Walkers become a few leaked photos
of john badly known as samuel Tarly
which were taken from filming sites as a
series
in its a measly in the old town with
Gillian baby Sam which could mean that
Sam at this point it will already learn
how to make Valyrian steel since these
scenes of Sam are going to be placed in
either episode 4 or episode 5 which I
know for sure is from the film set
director Matt Jackman was spotted
I'm sure the ginjury will play a huge
role in season 7 as well so if you'll
help John on his mission and we'll go
beyond the wall with him but I see
injuries having a much bigger importance
in the last season back in the third
season the new Sandra Valls ginjury from
the Brotherhood without banners ginjury
disappointed that Brotherhood so linked
to Melisandre said that he told he was
one of them he said that he told that he
was a part of Brotherhood without
banners so Mitch McConnell replied that
you're more than they're ever going to
be because of you the Kings will rise
and fall
let me repeat one part of Melisandre
sentence the Kings will rise and fall
because of you
I'm a veritable stranger by this was
pointing on his blood which shields for
blood ritual but what is most Sanja was
wrong and she was wrong while convincing
Stannis that he was the Promised One
what if she was right about the part of
sentence and we she said that the Kings
will rise and fall because of him but
what if she means the true meaning of
that what if the Kings will literally
rise and fall because of him as a result
of his own acts good for an example
ginjury called the fall of the knight
king by forging Valyrian steel swords
could the last link son of King Robert
Baratheon be brought back to do
something big something that will save
the whole Westeros let me know your
opinion on all of this in the comment
section down below
in conclusion ginjury will definitely
appear in the upcoming season with his
father's Warhammer vile in my opinion
he's going to play a much bigger role in
the last eight season I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next piece
[Music]
you